Ian's going to be really upset he's not
here tonight because we have the story
from Politico Vivek ramaswamy quote I
don't believe the 911 Commission report
the GOP candidate went on to insist he
was expressing doubts about the Saudi
government's explanation for the attacks
let me just say first and foremost you
want to talk about honesty in a
political candidate have them come out
and say they don't trust the 911
Commission report and I believe Vivek
ramaswamy is being honest I mean this in
any traditional sense any traditional
political consultant would be like what
did you just do you nuked your campaign
but Vivek is telling you actually what
he thinks and he's completely correct
let me let me read this
political reports the fake ramaswamy
cast doubt on the veracity of the
government's explanation for the 9 11
attacks saying he didn't believe the
findings of the 911 Commission
he said quote I don't believe the
government has told us the truth I'm
driven by evidence and data what I've
seen in the last several years is we
have to be skeptical of what the
government does tell us I haven't seen
evidence of the contrary but do I
believe everything the government told
us about it absolutely not do I believe
the 911 Commission absolutely not I am
tremendously impressed from this they're
they're trying to now claim he's like a
911 truther or it's like the underlying
argument no no no no no no that's total
BS if you believe everything the
government tells you you haven't read a
history book not a single one and I got
a bridge to sell you all he's saying is
something simple and I've said something
similar
why would any reasonable person think
the government issued a book explaining
one of the greatest security failures in
the history of this country they
wouldn't they would put out something
which is somewhat true but probably has
a bunch of gaps in it because they don't
want to reveal Secrets as to how we got
attacked because we don't want it to
happen again Vivek is correct you know
that can be there's some comedian who
has a bit that's like uh you don't need
to believe in all conspiracies theories
but you don't believe in any you think
the government
a thousand we're like we talked about
like parenting and lying to his own kid
it's great I wish I could remember oh
that's a good one yeah we're like one
we're like one Biden mishap away from
finding out that aliens did 911 anyways
But like everyone be like okay
I
I feel like I have to point out it's
like Vivek is
can is establishing the narrative like I
don't know the context in which this
came up it was being interviewed and
someone asked him explicitly do you
believe in this or if he just brought it
up on his own in his own interview which
I wouldn't put past him uh I I think
it's interesting that so often
especially on the campaign Trail you get
these guys who are like something's
happening at the board of all I'm gonna
comment on it oh something happened over
here and all coming out whereas Vivek is
like I want to talk about this now I'm
going to give you my opinion like that's
like a that's a very bold how does it
even come up that they're like do you
believe 911. he's like no if he had been
on this show like it would have been any
one of you guys to be like so let me ask
you a question here right for sure but
like Ian it didn't happen on our show so
I feel like I don't understand can I I
just want to play a quick snippet from
The Whitest Kids you know this is a 14
year old skit and uh I only want to play
a little tiny bit of it
waiting the president has asked me to
come out and make a brief statement
about the wire that just went out a
couple minutes ago
to make things short I will just confirm
that yes we do have a moon base and yes
we are currently experiencing some bear
problems now I will open it up if there
are any questions
uh yes I have a 10 no 11 part question
I'm sorry I only have time for two all
right let me get this straight so the
United States government is admitting
that we do have a moon base and that
there is a bear problem on said moon
base yes that is correct all right
follow-up question
are you with us
no we are not and I would like to remind
everyone to keep the language civilized
this is the White House so he basically
then goes on to say he says stuff like
yes well the Bear's been a bit a lot
ongoing problem since the Wizards were
attacking and then they're like Wizards
and then uh let me let me jump right
there's a picture of the bear on the
moon let me let me jump to the end here
and give you the punchline Cycles we
believe they may be of the uh just a
thought more of a shot in the dark but
uh
we wouldn't happen to be invading Iran
today would we
[Laughter]
you got me
I fell for it I fell for it yes exactly
summed up perfectly 14 years ago by The
Whitest Kids you know it's so great
because we're experiencing it now we
have this we're like oh my God look at
vivec questioning the not 911 uh the
specific narrative that the government
gave out he's questioning it in the
slightest but guess what guys aliens
like I said the government's out here
batting a thousand they just get it
right every time I mean that that seems
so ridiculous that they would be upset
that he's questioning something also I
feel like the implication from this
article is like he's denying 911 right I
mean like are you crazy that's not
what's happening at all wouldn't it be
funny if there's like an alien spaceship
in orbit around Earth and they beam Joe
Biden up there and they're just like
what have you done why are you revealing
our presence and he's like come on man
they're gonna arrest me what am I
supposed to do got to do gotta throw him
something to get him off my back proving
he's like the least loyal person on
Earth or in outer space the UFO though
thing is a rabbit hole that's crazy I've
dug into a tiny bit if you look into the
past there were legitimate fed UPS where
they were creating disinformation
without within UFO research communities
and the reasoning was like I know it
sounds kooky but it's because a lot of
times they were actually sort of digging
into like secret stuff they're doing and
so then they take some UFO truth and be
like guess what dude I'm in the
government and I have some special
information for you let me tell you
about the tairerians from Saturn 25 uh
and then like this stuff just goes wild
and then so like I don't know for me
like I've been digging it a little bit
throughout this like the whole UFO stuff
and it's just like there's you can't
trust anything when it comes to the
government and Aliens like who knows
maybe they are real but I personally I
completely default the opposite way so
and what would like what would the
benefit be right now for them to reveal
it like we've talked about obviously
distraction from other stuff that's
going on but if the aliens are real what
does the government get from telling you
I feel like I just don't understand that
you'll listen to them because they
scared you with something else that was
just when they planned to release that
information it just so happens
some type of Scandal is coming not
non-human biologics have been recovered
now you must listen to us more I mean
stop questioning us you've put your Psy
op hat on though like as ridiculous as
it is alien's super easy to pull off
like you just have somebody come come
out leak some information like so you
don't actually have to have an event
that really occurs you could have an
event but it's like oh we you could make
up an event that happened a decade ago
you could just take 10 000 drones like
what what what's the the mavic Drone
they do those light shows and they can
have a ship appear in in in the sky they
can just fake it you know and then be
like oh what was that they'll do it in a
remote area everyone will film and
they'll be like it was for your own good
nobody nobody even cares at this point I
wonder you know they've they've tried
pushing the UFO thing so many times that
nobody cares anymore at all to the point
where when they came out and said
non-human biologics are recovered
everyone's like shut up dude even the
UFO truthers are like nah shut up well
they're like it's too expensive here we
don't these these things are for when we
have luxury and freedom and extra cash
you have made it so we can't enjoy these
crazy things because it's not fun to be
here right now is anyone extremely
challenging to live under these
conditions does anyone really believe
that Donald Trump would have kept his
mouth shut if there were aliens secretly
in control of things and even at this
point with everything they're doing he
would just come out and be like I'm
gonna tell you all because they're
trying to put me in jail aliens are real
and you just come on say it and then
they'd be like oh no he's unveiling us
but he won't he doesn't because it's not
true they're just lying I mean to be
fair they probably would never tell them
about the aliens if they were aliens but
uh right yeah maybe that's the issue
maybe you have you guys seen that viral
video where it's uh that old guy I think
it's like a foreman can former Canadian
Prime Minister or something saying that
aliens are real or something like that
and that they're telling us we have to
reduce carbon and reduce the population
and climate change wow exactly what the
elites are not weird you know but that's
exactly the point right exactly they
want it because the aliens told them
they have to do it also why would we
listen to the aliens that seems crazy to
me that was the plot of the of the
Independence Day movie anyways that the
aliens were here to to suck up our
natural resources but I guess if all the
natural resources are gone then it
doesn't matter they'll just pass Us by
so if we get rid of our natural
resources we'll prevent Alien Invasion
exactly so that's pretty cool baby
exactly yeah what the heck this is the
best idea of all time fracking in
America now it saves us
intergalactically yes why should I care
about the aliens like what's what what
is it right are they going to offer us
immortality or something or like
inter-dimensional travel or whatnot
because like I got to tell you
the happiness is relative we all live
our lives we have our goals we have our
passions we're living them when we reach
the point of interstellar travel I'm
sure it'll become a passion project for
many people Elon Musk certainly is very
passionate about space travel but what
do we need from Aliens like serious
question has like when people had no
refrigerators they got by and they were
happy and then there was you know there
were problems and challenges but what is
what is it is the aliens are going to
come to Earth and give us future
technology and make us all Immortal or
make the elites Immortal so they got to
do as they're told that's what I don't
understand like are we supposed to be
excited and wanting there to be aliens
or are we supposed to be afraid of them
because if it's we're supposed to fear
them then I understand why the
government is like yup they're here
listen to us the only people who know
about them because that's just asking
for compliance and if it's like the
aliens have something positive to offer
us I understand why the government would
keep it a secret because they're you
know the Arbiter of all good things like
I just don't understand where they fit
into anything that's relevant to my life
yeah it's also a big letdown for all the
like the hard line UFO conspiracy
theorists who've been waiting for that
confirmation for decades right because
they've been waiting for them there was
an interview with Dean hagland he was a
he was one of the actors in The X-Files
he talks about he's like the the sad
part about being a conspiracy theorist
is at the end of the day even if you're
right all you get to say is I told you
so they don't even get that now like now
they're just stuck with like now they
tell them they're real they're like
first of all I can't trust you whether
they're real or not and it's kind of a
letdown because gas is nine gazillion
dollars a gallon and everything's
expensive yeah yeah also conspiracies I
just feel like you're totally right Tim
if if Trump knew about the aliens I
definitely think he would have told us
especially since he's the one who
relaunched space command I feel like he
would have been like I have good
evidence oh maybe that's why he did it
yeah maybe that's it okay so then why
would he want it to be in Alabama and
why would Biden want it to be in
Colorado that's just that's just that's
procedural bickering or do they like
walking to fight the aliens but that's
what I mean did Trump say they're
defeated by water you need to be close
to the golf what if what if that
Colorado wait wait I figured it out I
figured out I know exactly I know what's
going on check it out check it out
the aliens aren't here
they were here and they're coming back
and see the Democrats you know and and
the world economic Forum are like we
better get on our knees and do
everything the aliens expect otherwise
they're gonna be mad and Trump was like
no we're gonna build weapons and fight
back and they were like are you mad
they'll wipe us all out they're so
Advanced that's what's really it return
to the lizard overlords that's right so
Earth is like Liz world's biggest Airbnb
and they're just coming back and we've
left it a mess and they're just pissed
about it well you know the conspiracy
about like Planet Eris or whatever right
I don't think conspiracy is the right
word for these things more like insane
ideas you know or like Fringe ideas
because like conspiracies like people
collude together to do a crime or
whatever but like one of these online uh
theories is that there's a a planet that
comes within uh close within our solar
system every 2500 years and so that yeah
Nibiru Planet acts
and that it's it's it's coming back and
the Millions who live on it genetically
engineered humans to be like a slave
race or whatever to mine gold and stuff
like that it's a fun Theory and someone
comes back they just like scoop up some
people no no they come here and then
they take out the gold and then they use
the gold to uh maintain their atmosphere
or something at an all-time high right
now it's great it goes somewhere down so
many rabbit holes that's where Nephilim
like there's you can connect with an
ethelm and all sorts of stuff it's a fun
one genies and
on my show and we were legit we're
talking about Nibiru and how it connects
the feeling it was a fun time it was
wild but it was something
yeah I feel like that's not bad then
like we can just trade them gold I mean
I guess they like enslaved Us in this
this Theory I'm not sure as long as we
keep the silver I'm okay with it it
would just be you know more fun if that
stuff was true and I think people want
that stuff to be true because the
reality is life is mundane you know I
tweeted this earlier like how is it
people always say like how did it get so
bad in insert country and it's like it
never really did and what I mean by that
is every day something small happened
that no one thought was a big deal and
then finally crazy stuff was going down
that people thought was normal to the
outside world when they write the
history book and condense it all we're
like how did they go from this to this
it's like no one noticed but even now
people don't even notice crazy stuff's
happening now and they just don't pay
attention their their algorithms they
look at every day are pointing them in a
different direction so they're kind of
oblivious to the fact that a lot of this
craziness stuff this crazy stuff is
going on that's why I think Trump's
trial is so confusing to so many people
because it seems like they're just going
after him and they like they keep asking
him to turnover documents and then turn
to come up with charges against him and
like this actually happens all of the
time it's just that we all know Trump
and we have this information so rather
than for me to have to explain like one
person in their story and unique things
and get everyone to understand it we can
all say oh yeah I remember Trump oh wow
this is happening becomes much more
relatable it's it's something that's
gone on for a long time we just are
suddenly realizing it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time